Position d'départ ! Bien le silence partout s'il vous plaît
annonce prise 3 2e <3
T'aurais un chargeur toi ? Non.  Bonjour ?
Et là, il sort son Gun
bienvenue sur le tournage de "Lunaire" !
lunaire ça raconte l'histoire de deux frères qui sont très différents: l'un très créatif, trop créatif même et l'autre pas du tout plus
réaliste et terre à terre.
Ben ça tu vois c'est une petite fille qui s'est réveillé dans un corps de papi.
Pour vivre une aventure qui va combler les différences "non non non non,  tu fais ce que je te dis !!! " Il y a ce fameux voyou qui arrive
dans une soirée qui veut juste un peu de silence un peu de calme
il est poursuivi par les flics et c'est sa part un petit peu en vrille et il devient très menaçant en sortant une arme beaucoup
de tension beaucoup de danger.
Lui il continue à s'obstiner, elle, elle va pour appeler les flics
Bam ! Qu'est tu fais ?
Non, non, trop pas !
J'ai inventé cette petite situation pour que en fait les deux personnages, les deux frères sont obligés de collaborer
"Sonia, elle a 2 personnalités " (Sonia panique), "L'une sage ... (Sonia panique toujours)
Il impose une sorte de mise en scène à
ses autres otages qui sont contraints de faire, mais, qui donnent le maximum pour faire
Je me suis inspiré de ma relation avec mon grand frère, on n'avait pas à tomber d'accord sur ce qu'on aimait dans la vie et
puis aujourd'hui la vie nous a un peu plus rapproché, on est beaucoup plus proche aujourd'hui qu'avant.
"Oh putain, oh t'es trop con (dit avec amour)
* Musique *
Quand j'ai commencé à écrire l'histoire
j'ai demandé en tout cas l'avis sur le sur le script à Raphaël Descraques qui a tout de suite réagi, il a dit : Oui, ça, ça me parle
Les enjeux étaient assez fort et le bluff été assez payant et de faire peur à
quelqu'un qui nous fait peur moi ça me parlait pas mal
On arrive à faire croire au voyou qu'il faut partir parce qu'on est très dangereux ! Ce qui est faux, regardez moi, je ne suis pas dangereux !
"Personne n'a 500 euros ?, vous avez pas de la petite monnaie ?"
"Personne n'a de la petite monnaie ?!" (dit-il en rigolant en imitant Sonia)
C'est mortel, c'est ouf ! Une fois qu'on a un petit peu travaillé ensemble sur le scénario je lui ai dit bon bin est ce que tu
veut le réaliser et je suis vraiment content d'avoir fait ça avec lui parce que
il a sa méthode il a une exigence aussi vis-à-vis des comédiens et la mise en scène "sur le contre champ de partir un tout
petit plus comme une flèche au début  et donc te peux partir comme une flèche au début
Et te caler un peu plus au milieu."
Après, je fais un mix ?
Top Tiphaine
Dans une première version, on n'était plus sur
Camille faisait croire aux voyous que ils étaient une mafia très russe et j'ai pu un peu m'amuser a
rajouter par exemple le personnage d'Henriette, une sorte de mama qui gère des centres d'orphelins assassins.
ça paraissait un peu évident que j'incarne le petit frère et en fait en
cherchant des comédiens vraiment sur la fin les dernières semaines on s'est dit ah non mais on change le change en inverse les rôles
' Moi je suis le grand frère " "C'est mon grand frère"
C'est une démarche de comédien c'est assez intéressante et puis Gaspard est vraiment parfait pour faire le mec dans la lune. "Putain mais Camille !! Arrête !"
J'vous laisse admirer ma nouvelle coupe de cheveux
On a passé des castings pour trouver des gens, on a regardé  plein plein plein plein de comédiens et
allés un petit peu plus loin peut-être qu'on voit moins souvent sur internet ou même pas du tout
là on a plus écrit en pensant vraiment aux personnages
On est les jumelles Olive
je ne peux pas vous dire que je joue la science et que je joue Sonia ! Moi je joue le rôle de ..... "Homme grand"
plus communément appelé le geek qui fait chier
"C'est pas du tout pour une dédicace c'est plus pour vous donner un petit coup de main" Et je viens pointer du doigt une incohérence
évidente : comment Déméthra peut-elle voyager avec sa relique
Alors, elle vient
d'un autre monde! "Non, ils ne sont plus sur Zaraks depuis au moins quatres pages !"
le tournage s'est très bien passé, il y a beaucoup beaucoup de lieux, par contre c'était quand même compliqué de tout
tourner un peu en même temps en très peu de jours. Pendant qu'on tournait par exemple la librairie le matin
l'équipe commençait à monter les lumières à l'appartement donc tout était fait un peu en même temps. En parallèle on avait dû
tourner des séquences aussi en extérieur où il y a le personnage du voyou qui se balade et qui va se paumer. Donc tout ça a été
tourné, un peu improvisé dans la rue.
Puis dans l'appartement il n'y a pas  beaucoup d'espace...  "Pour avoir l'autorisation de le prendre en photo, te ne regarde que lui, ok ?"
"Quand tu tombes sur le PQ,  tu le lâche plus du regard"
"Courbes-toi un petit peu Gaspard"
silence pour la figuration s'il vous plaît, moteur !  on a essayé d'apporter un souci du détail
Dans cette séquence là tout le monde se débrailler. Le livre qu'il dédicace à la fin, c'est un vrai faux livre
qu'a fait Camille Dabrowski, qui n'existe pas : ni le livre, ni Camille
En vente dans aucune librairie !
le deuxième romAIN !!! Elle m'a trouvé aussi des fautes d'orthographe le 2e romain de Camille, au lieu de romAN. C'est parce qu'il est papa *puis paroles incompréhensibles*
On a voulu faire un court métrage qui se rapproche le plus possible du cinéma
Le chef-opérateur nous a fait une image et une lumière si julien a passé un petit peu de temps dessus j'avais très envie
d'essayer un peu autre chose que ce que je fais d'habitude
avec des machineries qu'on n'a pas trop utilisés jusqu'ici nous sur le web d'aller voir dans des plans un peu plus
aéré où moi, au montage j'aurais pas le choix de le mettre telle qu'elle
"En fait, j'avais rendez vous sur Paris mais bon j'ai loupé mon train"
"Maman m'a dit que je pouvais dormir chez toi"
Ok tout le monde, votre attention s'il vous plaît ! C'est une fin de tournage (Applaudissement des acteurs)
Moi la musique c'est une partie qui est super importante. Les sons composés, c'est pas des musiques qu'on trouve sur internet
on a fait travailler Edouard Joguet c'est un
artiste que j'adore et on a aussi en
générique de fin est un artiste que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle Pomme pour terminer en chansons quoi comme à Bollywood !
c'est la réf
Je suis super content de pouvoir projeter en fait le court métrage sur un grand écran du coup dans un cinéma max linder
internet c'est bien parce que
je peux partager des vidéos avec absolument tout le monde et tout mais dans une salle avoir les réactions en direct
ça c'est assez unique j'espère et je pense que ça parlera
à beaucoup de gens qui sont tous créatifs. On a tous dessiné avec des crayons comme ça, en les tenant
moi je continue à raconter des histoires pour la suite !
*Musique*
Abonne toi ! Et coupé !